Film Courage: How do you think making WALLY
GOT WASTED helped you to move forward?
Adam William Ward, Actor/Producer: WALLY GOT
WASTED is my first feature so to be moving
forward after it?
How does it help me move forward?
It’s kind of amazing and I try to explain
this to people but until you’ve done a feature
people don’t believe you can do a feature
because so many people have failed at doing
a feature so just a lot more doors open up
in a way.
People know that you’ve done it and if it’s
at least half decent they think you can do
it again.
Actually I think I read something that 99%
of filmmakers make their first feature, they
never make a feature again.
So that’s how many people try to do this
and go “I don’t want to do this again.
This is horrible.”
You have to really love film to want to do
it because it’s so hard.
Like I said earlier it’s like 2-3 hours
a night I slept on WALLY and how many emergencies
would happen or whatever and everything comes
back on me so if you don’t like to be a
leader you are not going to like being a film
director.
You have to manage egos.
You have to manage…you have to keep your
cool under all circumstances and at the same
time make decisions.
You don’t want to put anybody in danger.
Your movie is important but you are making
a movie we are not curing cancer.
So let’s not endanger anybody or do anything
that is unsafe.
After you’ve done your first feature it’s
just a totally different respect you get from
people and opportunities open up way more
because now you are a real filmmaker.
I mean everybody kind of looks at you like
an amateur when you are making short films.
But after you’ve made a feature you are
in the pros.
You are competing with…once you make a feature
you are competing with AVENGERS.
You are competing with all of the movies.
There is no scale because you are competing
with them all.
Because the audience on Amazon can choose
AVENGERS or they can choose WALLY GOT WASTED.
So you are competing with everybody so that’s
why I take it easy on myself because I didn’t
have 500 million dollars to make a movie,
I had 70,000.
The fact that I’m even competing with these
movies and some people are watching my movie,
I’m thrilled.
Because there is so much content out there
to watch but you learn and opportunities just
open up.
They open up and you don’t know where they
are going to come from after you’ve done
your first feature so you’ve just got to
do it.
You’ve got to take your first chance.
You’ve got to learn and you’ve got to
fall on your face and you’ve got to do it.
Even if it never sees the light of day at
least you did it and you can do it again.